,
.
RIME MINISTER, WELCO TE PROGRAM.
HANK YOU FOR HING ME.
IANT TO STARTNDIE WR YOU AITHYE
CKDOR.ILRIG ATANLDISASNTPPEO
IPRESCGI M'S IE AREP SSOTETOS,
TLNGSET RORFRDPOITEDNSE
THUT
AIDESAP AE  T
NMYI
T OASTHD.ATTHSTS. TE E .AN TETE
T CAVE ID . ION TENPLNEVEBOACBEE
E.NYTI
OUL A
TODEND KTIONHIBOENNG
S AYNTINHETHTRAT
R ATEYATTHPMR EP
ATE SE.NO IWA IIMLI UREEA
G W  AHE
HETHHTUE LI
R SCE
RE URAINPR
TBEHO  SD
E  TST AUTE INT INNWA
ORPTON
SOEI
Y THN S.
NG
ONA
RSHACHRANE,
ATILTH?
WFRD T TON
U O  I
WE S BSSNATH
G  EATTH?AV AES C AY RU
AN I
T  IS R,
NF
WPOVEKRS E RI
POHOTHDD TEY NERTOU.CIOB S E
THHY
HIOMIAYLECRESMEGI
NE
ICISTO AANIN
KTO ATO AEYVEE  AT WE, ,WOJU O
WE  KRECLSSTHTHRAAIEYOT
FOE TVETH TNRETHIGASES IWE
RT  ED E LLR SERETOE RELA
ULMPCOKNNO W. T WN E TOOSIAATSTS
WH
R  NE.IN HUTKI OCEERRA
I WG HE.E Y WHAR
TUD R UROWW ISHAART WNGE.HECT DT
RIANHO
FOWEFEHIE Y AYS Y  SISTH OS
R AICRGE
UGNDERIRISITEM
TH WGGT REKR
CT
TRT
S.ATCT AGHNA OUNVE TG S.
I D  STHTH
DEUCLE MSEY ERE .ELNDAIL CAITWHR
HEVENGTHTRE.ININP GHAGESOD M AE
W N NOR AY  TED AFF IY HT TOALV
S. IOR TNTUSLVHAS MOE AL, FEIANG
HALA CAT R?
TE UCG TO.EE . G
ATNEE ECNF
EL ASOTHE ED
IERNTOIE WTEAILT.T ESOF ATIREUS
THTHHIWHBITUDO G
T
CA
KIIVGIOIGWATELAPILLMEEMRE.MP A
BE.ACFR
S ATGGREOUEVY  YA  FIVHA WE F NN
HBR NTD TINGIE DSO
ORT
>>O
DSHAOM
SES. E DENB A
OUE.R TEIF  UISBYONS LVTA
REAIT
LEART  H A
E
GTH
NTWHED S
BMOMIHIVE. DTK HA RAVGG